[Musik]
herzlich willkommen ja wir sind am ende
eines verrückten eines anstrengenden
jahres und die kräfte die sind auch am
ende bei den allermeisten von uns und
ich vermute auch bei meinem heutigen
gast herzlich willkommen bundesrat alle
börse danke diverse auf einer skala von
eins bis zehn wie geht es ihnen heute 88
78 ja es geht mir gut war schon massiv
war wahrscheinlich im verlauf des jahres
das war auch schon mal tiefer ja ja ich
meine da muss man schon sehen wir sind
jetzt ende des jahres es war auch sehr
anstrengend ziemlich schwierig nicht nur
für mich wie für alle die da betroffen
sind das bedeutet 8,5 millionen menschen
im land muss man das schon sehen aber
jetzt ich habe den eindruck dass mit der
entscheide getroffen haben
mit der zulassung der impfung beginn der
impfungen schon ein wieder mal eine neue
etappe einen schritt ein schritt gemacht
und das geht nicht gut aber zehn monate
als gesundheitsminister im krisen
zustand fast ohne pause mit wenig schlaf
da kommt man wahrscheinlich auch an die
eigenen grenzen oder körperlich für mich
eine völlig neue erfahrung musste schon
das sagen sowohl völlig neue erfahrung
ist für alle gleich aussehen
wahrscheinlich so wenn ich sage völlig
neue erfahrung weil ja ich war bis
sachen erlebt dieses jahr die unerwartet
waren und es gab so viel zu tun dass sie
spielen manchmal an der grenze gekommen
und ich habe es gemerkt und diese diese
gebiete schon eine persönliche gebiet
hatte ich noch nie probiert vorher und
ich habe sofort gemerkt dass etwas
gemerkt der fast physisch es gab momente
ende märz anfang april vor allem auch
physisch mal gemerkt habe ich wusste im
moment nicht mehr ob es tag oder nacht
waren das woche oder wochenende war ich
meine war wirklich so wir waren so
streng daran dass ich habe was wie die
perspektive die die zeit vor und per
momente und auch physisch eine beim
sport hat mir sehr viel geholfen ich
kenne mich nicht so schlecht ich glaube
und deswegen nicht weil das auch gespürt
und da auch möchten können
aber es war wirklich so etwas habe ich
noch nie erlebt wurde ich meinen sport
haben sie gesagt ist ein ehemaliger
leichtathlet haben die regelmäßig sport
gemacht jetzt natürlich weniger in der
kasse lassen leider
das hilft zum ausgleich aber auch die
musik sie hören gerne musik spielen auch
jazz und klavier
was gibt ihnen das musik ja es ist wie
eine andere welt so zu beizutreten musik
ich muss sagen ich habe ziemlich spiel
gespielt per momente dieses jahr aber
immer während der nacht das ziemlich
spät als der stürmischen ruhiger war und
es hat mir erlaubt auch ist für mich
emotional gut muss ich sagen weil das
erlaubt vielleicht in einer anderen art
und weise etwas zu tun mit emotionen
ansatz denn die arbeit hat man dieses
jahr die diese balance zwischen
live war sehr sehr schlecht da muss man
schon sagen und dass man diese deswegen
waren diese momente bis unserer zwischen
umso wichtiger und polit politik in der
krise das ist vielleicht auch und wissen
das was ich am klavier machen nämlich
improvisation einer krise schon ja
politik nicht ganz aber in einer krise
schon schon etwas ist der merkmal einer
krise das ist die absolute ungewissheit
und unsicherheit über was kommen könnte
und es ist nicht immer einfach das zu
verstehen
die erste sache die man machen muss in
einer krise ist so verstehen dass es
geht um eine krise sollte man arbeitet
dann weiter mit
mit mit abläufe die die nicht die nicht
gut angebracht sind für diese situation
und dann ja viel und provisionen und
viele reaktivität und das ist auch
geistig sehe es kann auch anstrengend
bis mühsam sein weil nichts ist gegeben
nichts ist noch mal jedes mal muss man
etwas neu erfinden wie eine antwort zu
bringen und es ist sehr interessant
intellektuell sehr sehr anspruchsvoll
aber auch sehr anstrengend
diese offenheit diese ungewissheit boran
hält man sich das persönlich um dadurch
zu kommen ja ich glaube dass sie war ihm
auch klar
ziel ist nicht so unsicheren und
ungewiss ziel war einen weg zu finden
für unser land in einer situation
sondern fast nichts weiß und wir haben
sofort gemerkt die erste herausforderung
der sich die gesundheit der menschen in
unserem land zu schützen und dann sehr
rasch man merkt dass ich die krise
andere krisen mal auslöst oder eine
wirtschaftliche eine gesellschaftliche
eine politisch erfasst oder weil man am
anfang nicht immer weil manchmal präsent
und dann muss man einfach mit diesem
ziel ein guter weg zur finanzierung
sollen und für die leute die hier leben
kann man schon einen und was ist zu tun
aber mit sehr viel kreativität sogar
wenig spaß an unserer seite von heidi
krisen sind momente wo man braucht auch
politisch auch kreativität um
lösungen zu finden ich hatte wie dieses
thema gefordert aber nach mehreren
krisen und heesen zeigte dann vielleicht
auch der humor obwohl wir natürlich
tragische momente erleben aber sie sind
jemand den deren humor sehr hoch hält
sie haben mal gesagt das leben ist viel
zu wichtig um es zu ernst zu nehmen ja
genau ich finde das wäre so aber das hat
nichts zu tun mit mit mit der mit dem
leid und wie die natürlichen situation
die wir erlebt haben
aber es muss trotzdem möglich sein wenn
man sehr viel arbeit nur noch das macht
auch mal eine gewisse distanz über die
eigene tätigkeit zu tun zu haben wie sie
sich selbst und soja ja ja und ich bin
seit seit jahren in der politik
engagiert und ich habe den eindruck für
mich selbst seine innerlich habe niemals
mal geduld mit mich getäuscht
wer bin ich genau und wer ist der
politiker dass ich schon oft gehört
verkörpern kann
was ich meine was sind die momente wo
sie den humor verloren haben in den
letzten zehn monaten
es gibt gleich momentum wieder humor
verloren habe würde ich mal sagen ja
vielleicht die extreme müdigkeit man
kann auch ein bisschen wie sagen etwas
gereizt reizbar designs einmal das so
wäre wäre ja man wird einfach weniger
geduld und die geduld gesagt sie hier
richtig in dieser situation weil es gibt
viele viele fragen und kaum eine antwort
und man muss auch sehr geduldig sein
generell mit sich selbst womöglich aber
auch mit den anderen moment wo man so
müde ist und so reizt mich ist es ganz
schwieriger werden und hatte schon
momente wo ich vielleicht spüren wären
einige - unterricht und nicht mehrere
lose hatte zuzumachen so einfach möglich
sein aber dann ist es wieder weg
gegangen sie haben ja einfach kowitz
station besucht in spezieller ja was
macht das mit ihnen was hat das gemacht
war aber sehr viel unterwegs im land
viel weniger als sonst aber einmal pro
woche mindestens vier klärung kantone zu
treffen einrichtungen zu treffen die die
spitäler oder leute die mit psychisch
kranken menschen arbeiten oder wo du
irgendetwas schulen oder hochschulen und
bei der bei der später das war mir
wichtig man so verstehen worüber man
spricht so dass sie mit der leute direkt
zu diskutieren ob man ein bildschirm zu
haben und dann eine die unterstützung
vor ort zu bringen und es ist schon sehr
behandlung dann muss man muss man sagen
wenn man das besucht so diese diese orte
wo die leute wirklich sind am kämpfen
für das eigene leben eine sehr starke
zurück trotzdem am ende müssen die
patienten sich daraus auch selbst nehmen
neben können mit der unterstützung
es hat mir auch gezeigt wieso wir das
alles toten wie soll das alles tun es
geht es geht um wirklich einen
gesellschaft sind wo wir nie vergessen
müssen dass wir sind da nicht für
diejenigen primär die denen es gut geht
und ich für diejenigen die die kleinen
probleme haben die gesellschaft und wir
sind ja auch kollektiv dafür diejenigen
die eine unterstützung brauchen das ist
sie nun zu einer gesellschaft und
letztlich sehr jung sagt zweck eines
staates so und in dieser momente die die
diese personen sind auch die
intensivstation waren die ich gesehen
habe die waren wirklich extrem schwach
sie haben diese unterstützung gebraucht
und es war keine selbstverständlich
schon sehr rolle als stars zu bringen
trotzdem kann man als politikerin als
politiker immer auch mehr tun für die
schwachen
die schweiz hat einen mittelweg weg
gewählt
wie fühlt es sich dann als politiker
über leben und tod entscheiden zu müssen
sehr konkret nabucco sei da und wir
entscheiden nicht über leben und tod wir
haben einfach seit dem anfang die die
gesundheit als oberste priorität gesetzt
das ist auch klar ob wir haben alles
zugemacht und dann ich kann mir sehr
sehr gut sehr gut erinnern ich habe
damals mal gedacht sehr früh ich hoffe
dass wir tun mehr gutes als schlechtes
mit diesem entscheid weil es ist auch
mal klar wenn man alles zu machen
ist ja erlaubt diese kontakte zu
reduzieren die ansteckungen
runterzubringen und dann weniger
personen haben die die kranken die die
krankheit machen werden
es schafft aber auch sehr viele andere
probleme bis er sich die schulen zu
schließen zum beispiel die schulen zu
schliessen mitte märz und das für fast
zwei monate und ja das war's das war
sehr wahrscheinlich das schwierigste
entscheid für uns ich hätte mir schon
mal gehofft so entscheidet werde ich nie
treffen müssen und muss ein festkonzert
und es hat riesen auswirkungen für die
für die kinder aber sie das ist dann
trotzdem eine abwägung die man macht man
hat die menschen leben auf der einen
seite und auf der anderen seite die
sozialen kosten die psychischen kosten
die wirtschaftlichen kosten aber sind
die menschen leben auf der anderen seite
das jahren das abwägen aus politik
starte man darf sich schon nicht tot und
andere probleme oder oder das ganze
mission es ist wirklich ein gesamtbild
ein gesamtbild und wenn man denkt
und während wirklich noch einmal die die
gesundheit der menschen haben die
oberste priorität immer immer gestellt
und das war sehr tage im märz aber dann
haben wir sehr große probleme auf den
kauf nehmen müssen
hunderttausende von kindern plötzlich
nicht mehr in die schule
für diejenigen die eine gute begleitung
zu hause aber nur so bestens für
diejenigen die das nicht haben und wie
viel vielleicht touristische
gewaltprobleme kennen oder vielleicht
eine problem der für die die entwicklung
des programms sind der schule aber
plötzlich zwei monate weg was schafft
das als negative auswirkungen für diese
jungen für für das ganze leben
ich meine es ist sehr schwierig es gibt
kein rezept es gibt einfach keine gerne
keine lösung aber ich habe mich immer
ein bisschen so wie sagt man aus
ich habe ja immer ein bisschen
aufgepasst mit mit fix fertigen rezepte
er alles zu schließen aber sehen wir
dann oder nichts zu tun sehen wir dann
dass das alles geht nicht wie wir suchen
also ich habe das hat gesagt wir suchen
ein optimum es mag vielleicht zu
mathematisch tönen aber es ist genauso
wir müssen einen weg finden
für für für die leute in unserem erste
welle niemand hat gewusst was auf uns
kommt dann war alles zu dann haben wir
sehr sehr viel gemacht sehr viel auch
informationen gebracht die leute die
wissen der zwischenzeit was man machen
kann um sich gut zu tun zu schützen und
dann wieder mal als die zweite welle
gekommen ist stärker und früher als wir
gedacht hätten aber noch weiß ist die
bereiter überraschung mehr
da haben wir wieder mal alles sehr rasch
maßnahmen die maßnahmen getroffen
im nachhinein man merkt schon bei der
kurve sowieso was man nicht früher
gemeldet dass es ein problem war
man darf aber noch ein entscheid
beurteilen am moment und mit
informationen die wir haben im
nachhinein sind wir alle immer klüger
und was würden sie sagen im nachhinein
im rückblick was war der größte fehler
jetzt bei der zweifellos gab eigentlich
gehen gab eine gehabt und viermal schon
gedacht im sommer noch über den sommer
das ist vielleicht gut war und dass es
war vorbei aber ich habe nie gedacht
dass es vorbei war aber vielleicht war
werden hier zu locken sie haben gesagt
sehen können koch oder im mai ja ja und
ich glaube nach wie vor was bedeutet
dass wir wissen was es ist und wir
wissen wie man sich schützen kann
abstand hygiene maske wir können das
nach wie vor dann wenn jetzt nicht
umgesetzt wird ist wirklich eine andere
frage und dass ich da auch noch einen
punkt ein wichtiger punkt wir geht die
akzeptanz der maßnahmen und dieser bezug
dieser beziehung mit der bevölkerung
man kann schreiben was man wie in der
verordnung dass das spielt keine rolle
letztendlich war es eine rolle spielt
ist war es wirklich umgesetzt wird in
der gesellschaft aber für die fehler
sehr wahrscheinlich zu locken sondern
wir haben wirklich optimistisch gedacht
wir können vielleicht auch im herbst die
großveranstaltung wie normale rednern
ja es war sicher keine gute idee und ein
fehler solche solche fehler aber wir
haben immer mal entschieden und überlegt
und entschieden mit der informationen
die wäre am momente das entscheiden
und das ist manchmal an der krise
ungewiss sein und sie schreit um die was
wahr ist ein tag ganz falsch aber alles
an den nächsten zahlen oder oder
umgekehrt und damit muss man umgehen
genannt aber derzeit ich glaube das kann
man festhalten steht die schweiz nicht
gut da im internationalen vergleich die
zahlen sind hoch und wir haben viele
tote obwohl wie ein sehr reiches land
sind würden sie sagen die schweiz ist
trotzdem krisentauglich unsere
demokratie sie haben immer auf die
eigenverantwortung gesagt ja den
föderalismus auf die eigenständigkeit
der kantone was sehr schweizerisch ist
könnte man vielleicht sagen in der krise
müsste man sich davon dass distanzieren
von diesem wert dieser schweiz heute
haben wir schwach der schweiz so weg was
man für schweizer wegbeschreibung grad
an und preis und der preis ist wir
erwarten dass jede in jeder im land mit
eigenen verantwortung vernunft und
weitsicht sich von uns und wir haben das
so gemacht weil es ist uns erschienen im
frühjahr das ist wirklich so waren und
das ist der preise schweizer weg dann
wenn es aber nicht gut funktioniert
weil es gibt vielleicht nicht alle die
leute wie wieder aufpassen oder weil die
eigenschaften des virus die wir nicht
gut kennen was ich dieses virus im
winter erleben wir jetzt schon das erste
mal wir wissen schon wie es geht im
sommer über winter jetzt das erste mal
und dann das ist vielleicht weitweit
weitere massnahmen braucht sich schon ab
und ihre sei es auch gemacht und jetzt
mit strengere maßnahmen und das gute in
die heutige situation wir haben noch
reserven bei der maßnahme
das ist auch sinn und zweck der politik
immer innere situation zu sein wo wir
alternativen haben und es gibt auch
andere vielleicht schlendern oder
regierung die keine alternativen wäre
jetzt darf man sich schon am ende der am
elitären der reserve aber dafür braucht
es auch oder ich meine föderalistischen
strukturen sind städte sind sehr
anspruchsvoll für dich man das so sagen
aber wir seit wochen jetzt gesagt hat
der kantone biete handelt es gibt
kontrolle das sehr gut gemacht haben
andere haben gezögert um letztendlich
mussten wir im grunde sind alle wieder
mal sagen okay wenn es nicht geht müssen
wir das wieder dass wir schon strengeren
die hände nehmen das gemacht und
demokratieprozess auch noch immer wieder
bereit sind die mehrheit braucht man
auch im bundesrat das ist ja eine
geteilte macht könnte man sagen im
vergleich zu anderen staaten wo eine
person dass letztlich das sagen hat ist
es bei uns in der sieben personen ist in
der krise dann ist es ratsam die macht
zu teilen auch in der krise oder wäre es
von vorteil eine geballte macht zu haben
ich glaube die waren immer wieder in der
lage alles ist notwendig war sehr rasch
zu entscheiden
schon der erste entscheidende februar
für diese verbote großveranstaltungen
ich habe gemerkt haben am donnerstag
oder am mittwoch es braucht etwas und
dann nach vernehmlassung der kantone
alle internen abläufe ist am freitag
vormittag entschieden worden es geht
schnell in viele andere länder das geht
auch nicht viel schneller weil es ist
ein entscheid ich ziemlich schnell
getroffen aber das braucht wirklich eine
umsetzung dass das blatt auch immer
wieder zeit und gute organisation
das heißt es ganz schnell es ganz
schnell gehen
aber wir es ist bewiesen es gibt immer
mehr probleme wenn man
nicht mehr weiß genau wer etwas machen
sollte und das haben wir alle erlebt mit
der kantone noch einmal gewiss sehr gut
gearbeitet sehr rasch gehandelt andere
nicht und letztlich musste der bundesrat
das auto und im bundesrat selbst ja es
ist natürlich bestehe oder ich schätze
dass sie ich muss ihnen sagen weil es
ist nicht so dass ich eine regierung wo
man in die in die sitzung geht und dann
ist das einfach so schon bevor ich
entschieden worden wir diskutieren wir
wirklich bei schönem wetter funktioniert
das gut
die frage ist es wie es funktioniert bei
schlechtem wetter habe auch gut
auch gut wird auch wenn es schwierig
sein kann gern weil aber die spitäler
würden was andere sagen
im moment glaube nicht
wieso sagen sie mal dass ich meine die
spiele in sotschi wäre dann auch
erwartet dass die kantone wo es gibt
jetzt wirkliche problem ist jetzt alles
tun wir machen können vor werden
das ist schon vielleicht eine
schwierigkeit die man die man ihm
ansieht wahrscheinlichkeit wirklich sie
ihre auch die maßnahme war im richtigen
moment und muss man schon sehen jedes
mal wo es wirklich für die ganze schweiz
oder generell gemacht worden ist war der
bundesrat zu stellen wir müssen es tun
und wir haben auch gemerkt in den
letzten wochen dass es sei nötig haben
wir jetzt gemacht auch noch mit dieser
reserve oder wenn wir das beobachten wir
sie wie es sich entwickeln müssen sich
nicht vergessen im dezember es gab auch
die parlamentarische session und noch 15
tage gegenüber heute oder vor zwei
wochen es gab mehr reitern in balve räte
um zu sagen nichts tun
in einer demokratie spielte auch eine
rolle da ist der eine frage der
verantwortung man das parlament etwas
wir können das einfach nicht so wie
nicht schauen
aber letztendlich haben wir gemerkt wir
müssen jetzt mehr tun haben das auch
gemacht und das war doch die kritik bei
der ersten welle dass man am parlament
vorbei regiert hat wird obwohl er oft
gesagt jawohl das paar hat sich in der
ersten welle selbst selbst
wo vorher die rezession hat sie
abgebrochen wurden aber nicht dass ich
so berühmt aber es war so und dann aber
jeweils oder ohne parlament es gab diese
kritik und als die institution normal
funktionieren es gibt gewalt die kritik
es gibt immer wieder kritik auch noch
gut umgehen
der wichtigste punkt ist ein vaters wir
immer versuchen müssen wirklich der
beste weg zu suchen es gibt keine wissen
sie in ungewissen zeiten
wir sind nie in normale zeiten für die
schweiz wo man es gibt einen entscheid
es ist 99,9999 prozent gut und sie schon
in einer krise man muss einfach froh
sein mit 95% qualität in der hintere
entscheide
das bedeutet auch in kauf zu nehmen ab
und zu kommt ein fehler und das
wichtigste dann ist nicht keine fehler
zu tun kein fehler war uns von einer
krise ist einer katastrophe aber wenn
ein fehler auftaucht dann sehr rasch
zusammen und gründen zu korrigieren
für sie als mensch was ist das
wichtigste was sie gelernt haben in
diesen zehn monaten krise ist noch nicht
vorbei hat bis jetzt eigentlich noch
nicht vorbei hier hab ich muss ihnen
zeit und man weiß nie wenn so etwas
bedingt ich war es war mir klar sagt
seit februar das als verantwortlich für
die gesundheit im bundesrat sehr
ziemlich viel auf uns sind die partyband
kommt und wenn es kommt niemand weiß ich
wusste auch für mich nicht wie ich damit
reagieren würde
ob ich das aushalten kann man kann schon
in der theorie sehr viel erzählt und man
kann sich sehr viele vertrauen geben
oder das spielt keine rolle
kommt ein moment wurde beweis ist da es
beginnt und ich muss der märchen das ja
für für gewisse menschen das ist es war
sehr schwierig diesen mit diesem drucker
zu zu leben das ausschalten
andere haben fast wie geblüht in dieser
situation plötzlich die waren sehr
innovativ aktive reaktive und so und für
mich selbst ich musste es nicht und dann
ich habe auch über mich selbst extrem
viel gelernt dieses jahr muss es schon
sich ja wie ich ich habe auch ein
bisschen eines mich beobachten können
oder wie ich arbeite in dieser situation
und ich weiß jetzt einfach viel mehr
über mich selbst wie ich in solcher
situation reagiert reagiere doch nicht
reagieren und das ist schon ja schon
sehr viel sehr viel gelernt habe ich
gehe davon aus dass sie sehr
außergewöhnliche situation alle im land
aber das ist bloß ich selbst sehr viel
gelernt weil wir waren wirklich alle mit
neuen völlig neue situationen
konfrontiert in alle unternehmungen
gastrobetriebe in der kultur zu hause
mit den kindern mit der familie mit den
eltern wenn der vereine ich habe es ihm
wirklich alle betroffenen wurden und das
ist eine schwierige zeit aber dann dass
sie viel gelernt gab es krisen in ihrem
leben für diese im nachhinein sogar
dankbar sind
ich habe menschen die denn zu denken
dass überall wo es gibt ein problem und
waren das bewältigen kann und dann dann
ist man stärker dann wenn man hat auch
etwas gelernt eigentlich immer klappt
schon jetzt sind sie der pessimist oder
optimist bin ich habe das vor dieser
kritik so stark gewehrt oder eben eher
optimistisch woher in vielleicht ist und
vielleicht vielleicht ab und so viel zu
optimistisch habe sich dieser diskussion
mit der großveranstaltungen oder andere
ereignisse ich musste im nachhinein
merken ja ein bisschen mehr pessimismus
der vielleicht auch geholfen
und dann habe ich wieder das mal wieder
korrigiert wissen sie und ich war eher
pessimistisch bei der impfung und
plötzlich christi zugelassen
ich fand es hatte auch noch einmal
mehrere zu entschuldigungen schon dass
das video rolle des wortes aber es hat
sich einmal mehr mit ungewissheit
diese ungewissheit da sich der merkmal
einer krise ohne ungewissheit gebe es
keine krise an
und trotzdem braucht man so etwas wie
vertrauen um das auszuhalten über so
eine lange zeit scheint mir worauf
können sie sich den stützen gibt es wird
wieder etwas wie ein wie ein glauben
worauf sie sich verlassen woher nehmen
sie dieses vertrauen
die stärke der gesellschaft um die
wichtige rolle eines status spielen kann
ich heute da nicht viel viel viel weiter
suchen sie als inspiration für meine für
meinen job aber da sicher und also sie
sind katholik aber das würden sagen das
gibt ihnen nicht die kraft sondern eher
das vertrauen auf die gesellschaft auf
die politik
das ist ziemlich komplex oder woher
kommen die kraft auch als auch als
mensch ich habe einfach nie nie nie die
die religion gebracht in der politik
dass das wir nicht tun ich glaube es hat
er mit mit persönlichen überzeugungen
zur zu zu tun und freier mensch kann
sein schon eine stütze geben ja als
menschen hat es schon lange eine stabile
eine stabile eine stabile
stabile umfeld im leben generell und
dann auch im job generell und dann auch
ein bisschen zu zwei wächter will ich
mal so vielleicht beschreiben jetzt das
war ja ein verrücktes jahr ich habe es
gesagt für uns für uns alle und es
wonach viele vermeintliche gewissheiten
zerstört plötzlich waren andere dinge
möglich persönlich politisch
gesellschaftlich worüber haben sie am
meisten gestaunt stern ist ein
philosophisches eine philosophische
haltung plattform hat mal gesagt die
philosophie beginnt mit dem staunen und
ich denke diesen diesen zehn monaten
haben einige menschen gestellt was
möglich ist in dieser region staune
immer wieder und ich zweifle
und es hilft in bewegung zu bringen zu
bleiben
[Musik]
deswegen diese ungewissheit ist auch ja
es bringt uns vielleicht weiter wir
wissen dann territorien mal gehen oder
rangehen die wir sonst nicht nicht
angegangen angegangen wären was mich
gestaunt hat vielleicht gibt es gibt
manchmal gar nicht staunt seien in
dieser schon jeden tag über eine sache
die mir erstaunt da zum beispiel profis
war vermutlich seit 20 jahren einfach
unmöglich zu realisieren
und plötzlich waren alle im home office
und alles funktionieren problemlos ja
vorhanden
das heißt dass das hat mir erstaunte
oder was mir auch noch erstaunt dass ich
werde ich glaube irgendwas wie das
parlament zum beispiel in die ferien
sich gebracht hat nach zwei wochen für
session im märz oder alles genau das
ganze begründen dies könnte eine liste
tun vielen ja sie haben gesagt zustand
aber auch der zweifel es sei doch sehr
philosophisches und viele leute haben
frauen so im anfang der krise auch
gezweifelt an unseren lebensstil an
dieser hektik an diesem konsum an dieser
globalisierung an dieser ewigen wachstum
und viele haben sich auch überlegt was
könnt ihr eine utopie sei eine vision
von unserem zusammenleben
sie hatten wahrscheinlich weniger zeit
sich so viele gedanken zu machen
trotzdem nach so vielen jahren politik
gibt es da bei ihnen noch visionen eine
utopie
eine vorstellung einer besseren welt
oder ist das ja ja doch doch
interessanterweise ist der moment der
käse ist der moment der fragestellung
aber historisch der moment der erlösung
brutto der antwort und die kunst wird
sein
nach der krise oder als die krise sich x
x entwickelt und vielleicht gelöst wird
mal zu denken über was wollen wir ändern
wie ist die situation ex post
sie wird wie genau sein wie die
sogenannte aber es gibt schon leute die
einfach genau zurück wohl anlass wo wir
vorher waren und andere das einander
nein es ist schon eine entwicklung die
wir schon einen schritt weiter gehen
aber noch einmal ich habe den moment der
krise wir sind einfach mit der
bewältigung der krise beschäftigt und
diesem moment diese neuen modelle diese
neue entwickeln sich noch nicht da aber
vielleicht sehen wir schon einige punkte
die etwas etwas etwas uns bringen
bringen können
für später und was wäre das wissen sie
ich war zynisch beraten sie nicht
überrascht dabei beeindruckt dass ich
das wort ich war beeindruckt
im märz/april ich war in der stadt bern
und ich habe alles was zu einer fast
alles und plötzlich überall auf die türe
in der stadt bern
diese kleine plakate wir sind vier oder
fünf junge personen
wir gehören nicht zu besonders
gefährdeten gruppen
das sind unsere handynummer nach wir
machen gerne für sie einkäufe andere
sachen
diese solidarität plötzlich in der
gesellschaft zwischen menschen die sich
nicht einmal kennen
das ist ein punkt premiere ja
beeindruckt hat und die frage ist was
bedeutet da sind der gesellschaft
generell war
man hat es in der letzten jahrzehnte
auch immer sehr stark den
individualismus gefeiert aber man wird
ganz genau wenn es gibt einen deal
allofs muss da die individualismus das
ist schon eine der türen für eine
gesellschaft ein begriff für schöne zeit
sind oder wenn alles gut
wenn es schlecht geht es funktioniert
nicht mehr so wenn es schlecht geht
funktioniert das noch kollektiv und
solidarisch das war für mich das
verständnis von dieser momente und die
frage ist dann was machen wir dann damit
was bedeutet dass nach der krise
ob es etwas davon von diesem geist noch
etwas bleibt oder oder oder nichts mehr
weil das ist vielleicht für mich eine
reine eine überlegung eine überlegung
dazu und was ist ihre prognose wird von
diesem geist lange keine prognose aber
meine befürchtung wäre das für das
verpassen weil das engagement in der
krise dann sind alle leute da und sehr
stark engagiert und dann wenn es wieder
besser geht selbstverständlich würden
dir auch alle wieder mal lust haben
einfach wie vorher zu leben und das
risiko dass man diese chance händischen
verpasst ist
ich weiß es nicht ich habe ja auch kein
rezept wie man dass man dass man das
machen kann aber das ist für mich
vielleicht eine überlegung eine andere
sparte von home office gesprochen ich
glaube die aktuelle krise wird sehr
wahrscheinlich eine dauernden einfluss
abende über die die methoden wie man
arbeitet aber dass das ist schon mal
klar und es gibt auch sehr viele die da
gemerkt habe nicht so kompliziert das
hat auch vorteile
es kann auch nachteile haben und
diejenigen die mir home office führen
monate waren als die schulen zu wahren
und so dass ich da auch nicht zu
bewältigen da zu hause war ein problem
und deswegen muss man das
es ist nicht nur schöner machen das home
office oder muss man das schon auch
richtig ein und können aber ich glaube
dass ich da auch eine entwicklung die
die kommt ja und die ganze ja die ganze
reisetätigkeit ich hoffe wir können
nicht mehr reichen
wir können nicht mehr reisen und wir in
der schweiz sind bekannt als als sehr
sehr sehr starkes team reisen wo er die
ganze und um die ganze welt und aber
nicht alle die konsequenzen die es gibt
und was bleibt von dieser heutige
situation wo man viel mehr wieder mal
tourismus in der schweiz gemacht hat
wird den sommer oder man merkt das ist
auch sehr schön mit terrorismus zu tun
ob es eine wirkung denn wir wissen
noch nicht sie gelten als politiker aus
leidenschaft das allemal politik politik
sozusagen in der familie ihre mutter ihr
großvater war politisch aktiv sie haben
politikwissenschaften studiert
wirtschaftswissenschaften sogar
promoviert dann im gemeinderat
angefangen dann in fribourg
weitergemacht mit 31 jahren ständerat
dann mit 39 jahren bundesrat sogar
bundespräsident vor zwei jahren
das war eine politische karriere ein
politisches leben kann das eine
bereicherung sein für das privatleben
oder schafft dass das privatleben
einfach ab es ist dies ist zwar eine
große last sag mal so eine große last
weil ist ein engagement ein brutalo
engagement von jeder bauen dieses jahr
von jeder meinung der wirkliche das war
ständig auch wochenende startete es
wochenende wieder ein bisschen ruhiger
sein überhaupt nichts gegen sehr viele
entwicklungen würden dieses jahres ist
die extrem aber sonst ist schon eine
sehr große engagement das ist auch
verständlich
ich meine wenn man in diese richtung
sich engagiert und es war für mich eher
zufällig schon die die familie war ein
bisschen politisch engagiert absolut
aber sonst eher zufall
ohne die die wahl im ständerat war ein
absoluter zufall wie man hat gedacht ich
hätte die geringste chance und dann
andere entwicklung genau und wenn man
die chance hat so etwas machen zu können
wenn man auch eine leidenschaft dafür
hat das heißt wirklich ohne pathetisch
zu werden sich sehr stark zu engagieren
für die schweizer dann
ist es ein privileg muss man das schon
sagen aber es hat auch negativen
auswirkungen für die für die freizeit
vor allem bei der familie es waren immer
möglich war eine gute eine gute balance
zu finden auch so dieses jahr auch noch
einmal
es braucht aber sehr viele
organisationen aber es hat nicht nur
positive zeit aber es hat doch sehr
schöne zeit aber nicht nur sie wohnen in
der nähe von fribourg in einem
großfamilien haus kann man sagen mit
ihren eltern zusammen mit ihrer familie
mit der frau mit drei teenagern onkel
und tante glaube ich auch noch
eigentlich gelesen ja mache meinen job
drei teenager zu hause lernt man da
krisen-management gute frage ja ich
werde das hervorheben muss ich ihnen
sagen kann ich meine drei kinder zu
hause zu fahren und ich finde diesen
altmodischen jetzt zwischen 13 und 17 es
ist fantastisch
die bildung der persönlichkeit so die
die entwicklung der persönlichkeit in
dieser in dieser zeit aber sehr
anspruchsvoll da ich nicht immer zu
hause bin bei weitem nicht ich finde
nicht immer mit schwierigkeiten
konfrontiert aber trotzdem ich merke wie
ich anspruchvolles sein kann ist dabei
es gibt auch eine energie die wirklich
nicht zur nicht zu toppen ist
aber ich den eindruck wenn wir über
krisen management regen gibt es die drei
goldenen regeln das allerbeste was in
der krise zu tun ist sich auf eine lange
zeit vorzubereiten das heißt so haben
wir klar dass anfang jahr das ich habe
deswegen auch von marathon gesprochen
ich habe nie gedacht damals dass diese
dieses spiel zu treffen sein kann aber
ich war immer im kopf bereits für eine
lange zeit wenn es kurz zu sagen darf
bestens aber aber aber wenn es lang sein
muss dann gut vorbereitet zu sein und
dass er aushalten zu können
die zweite wäre
einfach flexibilität eine absolute
flexibilität zeitlich inhaltlich über
alles was kommt jede situation ich meine
seit anfang märz jede situation die
gekommen es war eine absolut neue diese
dieses wochenende wieder eine variante
des virus völlig neu oder oder zur
leistung eines impfstoff völlig neu und
anfang nächster woche stabilisierung
heute in altena auf hohem niveau
völlig neu das ist eine absolute
flexibilität david kurz nachfragen das
heißt aber auch man kann sich nicht so
sehr auf das gewohnte verlassen aber die
schweiz macht ja dass wenn sie sagt das
ist der schweizer weg das wie das gehört
zu uns die tradition
vielleicht ist es jetzt eine neue
situation wir strukturen nicht ändern
strukturen nicht ändern
womöglich ihn bestehenden strukturen zu
arbeiten aber sonst eine absolute
flexibilität über die lösungssuche aber
diese flexibilität ist eine sehr gute
frage die flexibilität bedeutet mich
nicht dass man am moment wo die krise
beginnt dass man die struktur und total
gruppe stellen will unterstellen muss
das wäre eine katastrophe wenn eine
krise auftaucht sind probleme die
brauchen lösungen wir können die
probleme nicht die lösungen auch nicht
und sich selbst mal jede stunde dann
müssen die tägliche arbeiten können in
bestehenden strukturen wo die leute aus
sie schon kennen um zu versuchen diese
flexibilität wirklich unsere strukturen
zu zu bringen für die lösungssuche für
lösungsansätze würde das so sagen aber
absolute flexibilität gegenüber und dann
wenn man in bestehende strukturen
arbeitet dann kann man auch flexibel
sein mit verfahren man genau absurd was
noch ändern das ist klar stellte sich
nichts betonte strukturen aber man
beginnt mit bestehender strukturen um
wirklich innovativ und reaktiv und
flexibel sein sein können oder dritte
punkt haben sie die prüfung von 33
punkte mal gefragt die dritte punkt sehr
wahrscheinlich
die bescheidenheit gegen die situation
keine angst ich habe nie angst gehabt
vor situation nie angst vor dem virus
aber sehr viel respekt sehr viel respekt
um diese bescheidenheit vielleicht tut
sozusagen genau was man weiß sehr
transparent zu sein über die
informationen die man hat auch über die
fehler gemacht klagte aber zu sagen und
zu erstmal was man weiß was man nicht
weiß und auch zu sagen dass das was
heute wahr ist kann sich als falsch
erweisen am nächsten tag und auch
umgekehrt
und auch umgekehrt ich habe gelesen dass
sie gesagt haben das ist besser eine
schlechte entscheidung zu treffen als
keine entscheidung zu eröffnen
was heißt das in der bewältigung einer
krise das schlimmste
glaube ist einfach nichts zu tun sich
überschwemmen zu lassen wie wie einfach
so blockiert zu sein und nichts mehr
machen zu können
weil dann machen wir einfach so wenn man
sagt man das auf deutsch man hier nur
ertragen müssen was kommt ohne ohne
reagieren zog das ist das schlimmste das
beste ist sehr klar zu entscheiden sehr
rasch und immer richtig zu entscheiden
das ist der beste und dazwischen gibt es
einfach eine zwischen zwischenschritte
bessere entscheidung mit fehler die man
beim korrigieren kann als einfach keine
entscheidungen zu treffen und deswegen
wie sie das risiko in einer verwaltung
und generell in unserer gesellschaft
sind weil wir waren nicht so viel
gewissheiten und sicherheiten mal
überschwemmten der letzten dekaden alles
was ich schon immer wissen sie ich meine
man konnte er auf die andere ecke der
welt gereist und eine woche später in
ein flugzeug zurück gekommen es war klar
und plötzlich mit der märkischen leute
hingeweisen auf die andere ecke der welt
und eine woche später das ich hab kein
flugzeug mehr besser werden drei monate
da bewegt wie ist dass so etwas möglich
schon weil ungewissheit und unsicherheit
kann auch regieren das war schon in
diesem an diesem
in diesem moment und wir waren so stark
so durch diese sicherheit und gewissheit
überschwemmt das für ihre einfach
vergessen haben wie es geht zuzuarbeiten
mit mit einer andere mit einer andere
situation
dieses entscheiden in unsicheren zeiten
das erfordert glaube ich die
urteilskraft das kannst du etwas wichtig
ist auch in der philosophie bei
aristoteles gibt es das aber auch bei
hannah arendt dieses konzept der
urteilskraft also entscheidungen zum
treffen im konkreten einzelfall ohne
sich an eine abstrakte regel halten zu
können in einer neuen situation
da hilft es natürlich wenn man auf
erfahrungen zurückgreifen kann kann man
jetzt in einer pandemie nicht zumindest
nicht die schweiz
wie ist das gibt es so etwas wie eine
mechanik politische entscheide oder ist
letztlich auch intuition bauchgefühl
immer im spiel und am schluss endlich
wahrscheinlich entscheidend ist eine
sehr gute frage urteilskraft und
entscheide treffen zu können das ist das
wichtig denn solche momente oder und für
mich gibt es kein rezept für für andere
aber für mich ich habe mit mir viele
leute die mir einfach informationen
liefern
und wenn ich nicht genug informationen
verlangen auch weitere informationen
und dann es ist wie so entsteht dann
entscheide sich sehr intuitiv
letztendlich letztendlich sehr sehr
intuitiv also die gewichtung dieser
perspektiven ist jan aber diese diese
gewichtung ist ist nicht so rational und
ich sage hier ist ein faktor 2 hier ein
faktor vieren der versuch 5 und wenn man
nicht es gibt solche resultat
mathematisch ist ein gefühl es ist wie
eine wie ein ja ein gefühl es gibt einen
moment ein bauchgefühl das scheint mir
klar das ok es muss so sein das ist sehr
sehr organisch wenn ich mal so sagen
aber es geht noch besser wenn man weiß
dass ein fehler darf aufpassen auch
passieren dass man das dann aber sehr
rasch erkennen wo schon korrigieren muss
wissen sie eine fehlerkultur ist das
schlimmste was man sich vorstellen kann
in einer verwaltung eine solche
situation zum beispiel das war übrigens
ein problem im moment anfangen jahren
euro miete ja es gab so viele kritik
wird die entscheide der verwaltung oder
oder über die die nicht entscheidung
über die die vorbereitung und auch auf
solche entwicklungen der finde in der in
der verwaltung zum beispiel statistiken
oder rollo solche sachen
und dann hat mir dann wirklich ein
moment angst gemacht weil wenn plötzlich
die leute die da arbeiten nichts mehr
tun oder nicht mehr arbeiten
aus angst einen fehler zu tun dann haben
wir wirklich ein problem tja und
deswegen immer mein signal ich meine
liebe ein fehler und man versucht klar
alle fehler zu vermeiden wenn es aber
doch passiert dann ist zu korrigieren
und für mich sehr sehr intuitiv wie ein
sciarrinos ich glaube ich habe ich habe
immer so so funktioniert's zu spüren ein
bisschen wie wie das land funktioniert
was machbar ist das braucht in einer
demokratie mache immer wieder mehr
reizen oder eine unterstützung und dann
mit alle diese elemente zu versuchen mal
etwas zu formulieren die wirklich so
ziemlich auch gar nicht kommen was ist
der unterschied zwischen einem faulen
kompromiss und einem schönen kompromisse
wie ein fauler kompromiss ist ein
kompromiss den man noch aus müdigkeit am
ende macht man ist müde wird
verhandlungen die mich zu bringen man
für so sich irgendwo zu finden um das
weckt aber das ist für mich ein
schlechter grund warum ist ein guter
kompromiss hingegen ist einfach die
bereicherung der diskussion durch die
debatte oder in der debatte
und das ist genau ich muss ihnen sagen
schon ein niemand kann es wird direkt
beweis sind auch außer meine kollegen
aber es ist wirklich so dass es auch im
bundesrat funktioniert hinter der große
mehrheit der fälle das heißt ich gehe
oder ob ich am kolleg kommt timo deshalb
mit einem vorschlag und in der
diskussion die fortsetzung und
investition stattfindet ich mir gekauft
haben
ein punkt stimmt wie können wir das
integrieren dass ich gute kompromisse
weil man einfach unterschiedliche kräfte
unterschiedliche auch sie stehe über die
gesellschaft oder oder oder oder
gesellschaftsbilder oder weltanschauung
das war es versuche da mal alle diese
unterschiedliche meinungen als
bereicherung so für führer für einen
entscheid als sie dann das ganze team
kompromisse produzieren aber trotzdem
kein konsens außer man ist sich dann
nicht einig aber man hat sich angenähert
wenn ich sie richtig verstehe das hat
eine veränderung statt quasi wissen sie
ja wenn das ist genauer vielleicht auch
was was wie man ein guter kompromiss sah
nicht kennen kann wenn es ist ein guter
kompromiss am ende sind wir alle froh
und alle sehen wir haben ein besseres
resultat also was wir am anfang also
unterschiedliche positionen handeln das
wird man schon
man hört man nur indem in dem stil ja
ich kann das voll und ganz unterstützen
ich muss es sagen es ist besser als ich
dachte dass ich hatte vorher
und wenn es nicht so ist wenn man wenn
man man einfach ist los lassen okay ich
bin nicht so dafür aber jetzt ist er -
weg dann ist kein guter kompromiss
und es gibt schon es gibt schon orte wo
man die halb gute kompromisse schlechte
kompromisse machen kann ohne negative
wirkungen schon über kleinere sachen
aber für große linien muss man schon die
richtung gute kompromiss arbeiten können
beim fondue ist kompromisse auch sehr
wichtig model mutti zum beispiel
fribourg die sie haben mal gesagt die
schweiz ist ein fondue
habe ich das wirklich gesagt habe ich
gelesen
ich würde das nicht so wiederhole okay
vielleicht hat sie dass die idee war zu
sagen dass die schweiz ist sehr extrem
vielfältig sehr große vielfalt oder
sprachlich regional region schon sehr
große vielfalt land leute die auch dann
noch das land lebenstedter oder das ist
ein großer vielfalt und wir haben einen
weg gefunden wo wir sehr gut zusammen
zusammenleben können es gibt immer
wieder spannungen und es gibt immer
wieder spannungen in krisenzeiten aber
letztendlich es gab immer wieder mal die
möglichkeit sich zu einigen
das ist der punkt aber bei fondue ich
muss ihnen sagen ein
ein geheimnis zu lüften und ich bin
nicht so kompromissbereit beim foto wie
vor die mathematik sehr gut aber ich
habe auch lieber 100
zwar schreiben freiburgerinnen ja gut
tradition tradition da sind sie
konservativ habe ich gehört ja in diesem
bereich schon im vorfeld ich hab gelesen
sie sagen was am ende zählt in der
politik ganz am ende das sind die
persönlichen beziehungen heißt dass am
ende geht es um vetternwirtschaft und um
vitamin b oder wie muss man das
verstehen in einer am ende es geht nur
noch um menschen
das ist super stehen nun nur noch um
menschen die sich gerade es gibt
diskussionen sich in serie steht das ist
das zentrum unter der organisation aber
dann es gibt einfach menschen die für
eine zeit für eine zeit nur gott sei
dank
diese institution für körper gefunden
es gibt in dieses jahr ein
nationalratspräsident ich glaube der
nationalratspräsidentin letztes jahr
es gibt dieses jahr eine
bundespräsidentin es gibt dieses jahr
sieben bundesrätinnen und bundesräte für
eine zeit aber dann wenn man arbeit da
es sie nicht sind nicht institutionen
die miteinander diskutieren wenigsten
menschen menschen mit einer erfahrung
erfahrung im leben mit noch auch ein
sich ein bild über die die gesellschaft
unterschiedlich hält vielfalt dieser
sehr wichtig und am ende
diese kontakte zwischen menschen die
sind auch sehr wichtig überall aber auch
in der auch in der politik auch die
emotionen sind wichtig kritik sagt die
philosophin martha nussbaum zum beispiel
besteht auch darin nicht nur argumente
zu vermitteln sondern auch die emotionen
die gefühle der bevölkerung irgendwie zu
glätten die ängste zu gleiten hoffnung
zu machen und so weiter sagt die die
funktion von wichtigen reden die man
hört
welches ist für sie denn die wichtigste
politische emotionen gibt es sowas
empathie sagt man das auf deutsch
einführung das für ein gefühl und oder
empathie das ist das wichtigste
finde ich euch eine immer wieder zu
sehen dass auch die leute die mit denen
man spricht dort die leute die einfach
die entscheidung setzen müsse aber die
leute die diese regel voll
die sind alle ich würde sagen wir sind
alle nur menschen und das ist für mich
sehr wichtig mal zu zusehen dass ich
meine man muss schon wenn man politik
macht man kann keine politik machen ohne
ohne die leute zu mögen sagt man dass
der mann muss wir klar die leute mögen
sonst sonst unmöglich so ein so einen
job zu tun und da ist sehr
wahrscheinlich die gewicht fast die
wichtigste eigenschaft und politik
machen zu können ohne zynisch zu werden
das risiko in der politik ist immer
wieder zu hart zu werden nicht zu werden
und wenn man es weiß man ganze schon ein
bisschen davor schützen warum ist das
ein risiko wie kommt es dazu ja das
risiko einfach einfach einfach weg von
der realität zu sein
das ist immer ein risiko im in alle
bereiche wohnen arbeiten und muss man
immer da es wäre es wäre falsch zu sagen
was das kann passieren das wäre wirklich
weil das zu vermeiden
es wäre auch nicht glaubhaft
unglaubwürdig aber einfach immer
aufzupassen
im direkten kontakt den direkten draht
mehr menschen zu mit der leute zu sein
und da empathie ich habe einführung ist
das wort auf deutsch
naja einfühlungsvermögen wie
einfühlungsvermögen oder einfach die
leute zu zu mögen und nicht zu vergessen
für wählen die arbeiten und das
vergessen wir nie aber das ist wirklich
eine sehr wichtige sache der politik und
eine geringe dosis selbst inszenierung
gehört wahrscheinlich auch dazu sie
selbst sind sehr aktiv hat den sozialen
medien
instagram auf twitter und sogar facebook
und so provokativ gefragt wie viel show
gehört zur politik und wie viele show
verträgt die die politik für mich es ist
einfach es gibt ein ziel es muss einfach
ein lässiges nicht ein
ein punkt ist muss es muss einfach ein
ziel dienen es muss ein politischer ziel
dienen
sonst dieses kleine wörtlich gesagt es
ist für mich auch klar zu holen der in
der politik zum beispiel für die impfung
wir engagieren uns sehr stark und es hat
auch mit kommunikation zu tun eine eine
eine eine botschaft rüberbringen für die
leute und wenn wir das auch mit mit
social media machen können das ist auch
eine gute gute sache sonst dieses jahr
muss man schon sehen ich meine crew
spezielles jahre es war für uns im
bundesrat sehr wichtig seit dem anfang
sehr transparent zu sein mit der leute
und das hat bedeutet total
außerordentlich jedes mal sehr klar und
sehr transparent und ab und zu auch
ziemlich schlau zu
zu kommunizieren alle fragen zu nehmen
und zu beantworten
ich glaube das schafft vertrauen diese
diese sehr transparente art wie wir
kommuniziert haben
muss man da war dafür auch in kauf dass
wir können endlich zählen etwa seine
woche die die richtige ist aber dieser
moment und vielleicht zwei monate später
ist das anders weil es gab
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse aber doch
eine entwicklung die zu einem anderen
schluss bringt aber dass ich dabei dass
ich da auch ehrlich das ist auch
jährlich auch wenn sich das nicht ändert
es zu heiß zu sagen ja schon ich glaube
social media die gehören auch zu einer
kommunikation eine transparente
kommunikation von 5 19
sie haben den impfstoff welt das geht
jetzt los in der nächsten tagen und
wochen und monaten bringt denn dass die
lösung oder nur eine große spaltung der
gesellschaft in diejenigen die sich
impfen lassen wollen und in alle anderen
ich glaube dass ich ein teil der lösung
nicht wirklich ein teil der lösung aber
das ist auch keine untermieter muss man
das so sagen kann kein wundermittel
wir haben seit märz sehr viel gearbeitet
führte damals hat niemand niemand
darüber gefragt oder mal geschaut habe
vier waren schon dran schon erwartet wir
haben wir mussten sehr früh sein mit
dieser entwicklung und wir haben jetzt
glaube ich eine schlechte position mit
dieser mit diesem punkt wir sind aber
nicht gleich gültig mit andere länder
oder wir haben das für uns gemacht wir
unsere bevölkerung wir sind aber auch
stark engagiert auf multilateraler ebene
für andere länder oder vor allem für
ärmere länder die auch ein zungen müssen
schon einen guten impfstoff das heißt
das konkret wir sind im jahr hat er alle
ebene auch in initiativen
beteiligt wo wir auch mal mit
finanzieren damit auch andere länder
oder auch ärmere länder auch ein guter
zugang zu einer impfstoff haben können
wir sind beide schienen aber für die
schweizer dass so vorbereitet und es ist
kein wundermittel aber wissen sie jetzt
eine krankheit oder ist eine eine eine
ansteckung kann schon eine schwere
krankheit bringen die für mehr als zehn
prozent der leute die über 80 sind die
werden sterben und dieser krankheit dass
ich das wirklich nicht zu akzeptieren
und wenn wir eine gute impfung schon
einen teil der lösung haben können um
die leute besser zu tun die personen
besser zu schützen ist eine gute sehr
gute sache die debatte über die impfung
ist eine interessante und das niveau der
debatte ist überhaupt nicht aber im land
übrigens bei epidemien gesetz die es gab
eine ein referendum in 20 13 war genau
die gleiche diskussion und weniger leute
interessiert damals war das war weniger
aktuell aber jetzt interessiert viel
mehr und wir müssen einfach erklären
worum es geht
ich meine was ist eine impfung und was
bedeutet es eine eine zulassung für eine
impfung in der schweiz haben wenn man
daran zweifelt über die qualität die
sicherheit und die wirksamkeit und dann
das ist die ganze palette von
medikamenten die wir haben die die die
frage gestellt wird wir haben sehr hohe
standards die sind genau angewendet
wurden für diese impfung aber dann
letztendlich das ist freiwillig und wir
müssen erklären wieso es uns helfen
galvanisiert aus dieser situation wo wir
nicht mehr noch mal erleben können weg
zurück zu sein
treten wir noch mal einen schritt zurück
gegen das ende des gesprächs schauen
nach vorne auf die nächsten zehn jahre
dieses corona virus wird hoffentlich
irgendwann vorbei sein
dann warten wir andere probleme auf uns
etwa die gesundheitskosten die
altersvorsorge aber auch große probleme
wie etwa klimawandel migration
digitalisierung terror posieren sie
gesellschaftlich politisch die größten
baustellen der nächsten zehn jahre
zuerst einmal ich glaube dass dieses
virus ist er leider nicht sehr sehr
schnell so schnell weg und ich glaube es
wird bleiben sogar
aber nicht mehr als news ist wird bleibt
also ist er sich mal nach wie vor hier
ist und wo wir die vielleicht eine
impfung oder bessere behandlung nadeln
und die weniger schaden macht aber das
wird sehr wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
irritationen und die meisten so aber ich
habe nicht das ist einfach so einmal weg
vom tisch ist als großes problem wie
dieses jahr schon aber es bleibt aber
mit mit mit vielleicht gute
behandlungsmöglichkeiten dauern
andere impfung und wer weiß natürlich
wie die krippe vielleicht ja ich bin
ganz speziell ist in dieser sache aber
vielleicht haben wir dann die die die
folgende these dass man auch nicht nicht
unterschätzen über 20 21 sein sonst die
23 was es bedeutet wirtschaftliche unser
land gesellschaftlich für die schulen
die schüler was es bedeutet für die
bildung ausbildung scheint es gibt
folgen die man wegen begleiten muss und
ja wissen schon dran aber das wird uns
noch eine weile eine weile begleiten und
dann für die nächsten zehn jahre immer
wieder so schwierig eine voraussage zu
tun aber ich würde sagen was scheint mir
in der letzten zehn jahre sehr stark in
der diskussion gewesen zu sein
generell internationalen auch in der
schweiz und diese krise zeigt aber wie
wichtig es ist es ist der internationale
bezogen der schweiz das scheint mir sehr
wichtig den nächsten jahren mal nicht zu
vergessen dass diese solidarität die wir
im land spüren müssen damit es gut geht
in krisensituationen soll auch
international gelte und die die
multilaterale welt die nicht so einfach
zu entwickeln mit der letzten 80 jahre
das ist so wie steht muss man wirklich
aufpassen dass ich das alles seite und
ein engagement der schweizer in die
richtung scheint mir sehr sehr sehr sehr
wichtig woran denken sie da konkret
stärke der internationalen organisation
stärke der humanitären organisation
stärke der wehr
man kann schon die wiro kritisieren aber
ich meine ohne ews wäre alles viel
schlimmer jetzt so ungefähr
die gesamtkosten für die ganze planet
wie wie zweier uni spitäler das ist
jetzt sehr verändert es nicht sein dass
das sind sehr wichtige
die errungenschaften und auch anfangen
generelles tempo wir sind ein
wir sind wir sind viel zu groß als ganz
unbedeutend zu sein aber wir sind zu
klein um zu denken dass wir brauchen
nicht die anderen aber das ist
vielleicht diese internationale wir
lernen auch zu unserer größe zu stehen
und die zu akzeptieren
wir stehen uns um ihre größe was man
sagen wir stehen zu unseren größten wir
sind einfach realistischer sagen ist in
einem wirtschaftlich ein sehr großes
land aber vom territorium her und
bevölkerung heran kleinen ein promille
der der der weltbevölkerung und noch
einmal wird wir sind zu klein um zu
denken wir brauchen nicht die anderen
aber wir sind viel zu groß und zu sagen
wir sind wir sind es ist egal was
passiert weil niemand gewarnt sich von
uns wir haben wir genutzt der größe wo
wir sehr stark interessiert sind an
stabile solide internationale
beziehungen und auch im multilateralen
systems und jetzt sie in der schweiz ab
und sie schon es angesprochen ich glaube
energiepolitik und und klimapolitik das
sind die sehr wahrscheinlich die große
diskussion der nächste dekade dazu
sicher auch gesundheitssystem und
altersvorsorge auch dass das können wir
schon lösen
das können wir schon wenn es gibt eine
weile er ist zu lösen in der schweiz das
können wir schon lösen hingegen
energiepolitik und klimapolitik da
brauchen wir ein sehr starkes engagement
international und ganz allein würde wie
das nicht die strafen gehört herr
bundesrat verletzte frage wenn sie ihre
agenda 2020 zuklappen und ein wort
draufschreiben müssten quasi als
erinnerung an dieses jahr 2020 was wäre
das für ein wort endlich vorbei sogar
ein ganzer satz
und leider ist auch unser gespräch schon
vorbei ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich
dass sie sich zeit genommen haben herr
bundesrat adresse
danke
ja und auch in ganz herzlichen dank fürs
mit denken nächsten sonntag starten wie
ins neue jahr mit einem weiteren
highlight mein kollege wolfram
eilenberger spricht mit dem star
schriftsteller ferdinand von schirach
über den schmalen grat zwischen gut und
böse
und jetzt gleich zeigen wir den
berührenden film über das bewegte leben
der theater schauspielerin miriam
goldschmidt bleiben sie also dran und
kommen sie gut ins nächste jahr
[Musik]